esta vez nos preguntan a qué números
deberían reemplazar la a y la b en la
tabla de multiplicar primero vamos a
asegurarnos que estamos comprendiendo
cómo funciona esta tabla de multiplicar
y observamos que sólo es posible
multiplicar números hasta el 6 entonces
esto funciona por ejemplo si yo quisiera
multiplicar un 3 por 2 entonces lo que
tengo que hacer es desplazarme al tercer
renglón 1 2 3 y después a la columna
número 2 es decir 1 2 es el renglón 3 la
columna 2 y efectivamente 3 por 2
es 6 otra forma de verlo sería que este
12 que está aquí es el resultado de
multiplicar 4 que está en este renglón
en el cuarto renglón por el 3 que está
en esta columna
de la misma manera si selecciono este 30
que está aquí puedo observar que es el
resultado de multiplicar el 5 de este
quinto renglón por el 6 de esta sexta
columna en la columna 6 5 por 6
5 x 6 30 y observando los renglones y
las columnas podríamos decir que los
números en cada renglón se obtienen en
incrementos del número de ese renglón o
sea este renglón que es el renglón
número uno va incrementando en 1 1 2 3 4
5 6 oeste que está acá el renglón número
3 va incrementando en 3 3 6 9 12 15 18 y
lo mismo ocurre con las columnas la
segunda columna la columna número 2 los
números van incrementando en 2 2 4 6 8
10 12 y así ocurre con todas y tiene
sentido por ejemplo en la columna número
5 este 5 es 5 por 1 este 10 se obtiene
multiplicando 5 por 2 15 5 por 3 es de 6
que está aquí se obtiene multiplicando
dos por tres y lo mismo ocurre con los
renglones en este renglón el renglón
número dos 2 por 1 es 2 2 por dos es
cuatro este seis que está aquí es 3 por
este 8 es 4 por 2
el 10 5 por 2 y este 12 6 por 2 y para
terminar vemos los 6 es este 6 por 16 6
por 2 es 12 6 por 3 18 6 por 4 24 6 por
5 36 por 6 36 y es realmente interesante
comprender cómo funciona la tabla de
multiplicar y ahora vamos a responder la
pregunta entonces el número a tendría
que ser el resultado de multiplicar 5
por 4 y todos sabemos que 5 por 4 es 20
y otra forma de saberlo sería recorrer
esta columna la columna 5 como 5 10 15 y
15 5 pues es el 20 y lo mismo pasaría si
recorre el renglón 4 4 8 12 16 20
entonces
es 20 muy bien
ahora vamos a ver ve ve es el número que
resulta multiplicar 4 por 5 allí en este
caso 4 por 5 también es 20 pero veamos
sería lo mismo que recorrer la columna
de los cuatros 4 8 12 16 20 o el renglón
5 5 10 15 20 perfecto entonces a es 20 y
ve es 20 y ahora nos preguntan completa
las desigualdades utilizando mayor que
menor que o igual entonces yo tengo que
comparar el número a y b y observó que
son iguales entonces seleccionó el signo
igual y esto ocurre porque 4 por 5 pues
es igual a 5 por 4 ya sabemos que no
importa el orden en la multiplicación
muy bien vamos a comprobar nuestra
respuesta
muy bien bien ahora vamos a hacer otro
otra vez nos preguntan qué números
deberían de reemplazar a la a y la b
es el número que se obtiene
multiplicando 4 por 5 que es 20 claro
porque es 5 10 15 y 20 entonces a vale
20 después nos preguntan por el número b
y este será el número que resulta de
multiplicar cuatro por cuatro y 4x4 es
16 si lo veo en la columna sería 4 8 12
16 y en el renglón también 48 12 16
entonces b es 16 ahora completamos la
desigualdad observamos que a es 20 y b
es 16 entonces a es mayor que b y
recordemos el símbolo mayor que es el
que parece punta de flecha que apunta a
la derecha
a es mayor que b porque 5 x 4 5 veces 4
pues es mayor que 4 por 4 4 veces 4 por
supuesto
comprobemos nuestra respuesta
bien
esto se está poniendo bueno vamos a
hacer otro
muy bien esta vez tenemos que el número
a es el número que resulta multiplicar 2
por 5 y 2 por 5 es 10 2 4 6 8 10
o si me muevo en el renglón de los 5
sería cinco diez quince veinte pero
bueno aquí está el 10 2 por 5 es 10 muy
bien y ahora el número b es el número
que resulta de multiplicar 2 por 6 que 2
por 6 es 12 vamos a escribirlo y podemos
también verificar que es 2 4 6 8 10 que
ya sabemos que aquí va el 10 y luego
sigue el 12
y en los renglones sería 612 muy bien y
ahora es 10 veces 12 entonces a es menor
que b y seleccionamos el símbolo menor
que que es este que está aquí entonces a
es menor que b porque 5 x 25 veces 2
pues es menor que seis veces 26 por 2
seleccionamos menor que muy bien
comprobemos muy bien esto está realmente
bueno hagamos otro más
otra vez nos preguntan qué números deben
de reemplazar a ive esta vez
está en el lugar del número que es el
resultado de multiplicar 4 por 1 veces
es 4 4 por 1 es 4 si lo vemos en la
columna de los 1 sería 1234 perfecto 4
y ve es el número que resultaría de
multiplicar 4 por 1 muy bien 1234
perfecto 4
esta vez a y b son iguales porque 4 es
igual a 4 porque 4 veces uno es lo mismo
que una vez 4 perfecto comprobemos una
vez más
perfecto hagamos otro más
esta vez y está en la posición del
número que resulta de multiplicar 4 por
2 4 por 2 son 8 2 4 6 8 y en la columna
del 4 sería 48 muy bien y b está en la
posición del número que resultaría
multiplicar 4 por 2 4 por 2 es 8 javier
se parece a la anterior entonces esta
vez a pues es igual a b porque dos veces
4 es igual a 4 veces 2 2 por 4 es igual
a 4 por 2 ya sabemos que el orden en la
multiplicación no importa comprobamos
bien